tomorrow marks 20 years since the
tragedy at Columbine High School you're
seeing just some of the names of those
who died at Columbine and in mass
shootings at schools since April 20th
1999 today we pay tribute to that
and as we look back we also remember the
survivors who still carry the trauma
with them every day we first met Josh
Josh lap 20 years ago in an interview
with 48 hours the magnitude of the
Columbine shooting was just beginning to
sink in for the then sophomore now lap
tells CBS Sunday morning correspondent
Lee Cowan how he's managed to move
forward with his life even though he's
never forgotten the past never said time
heals all wounds
couldn't have imagined a wound is gaping
as Colin by but unlike so many tales
from that day this one begins on a happy
note I love you huh Josh lamb a
sophomore at Columbine all those years
ago is now a husband and father of two
Stetson and JJ I was always looking for
something good trying to find the silver
lining did you find it I think I did
josh is dead Randy is also BB he's the
proud grandfather after all it's a home
full of light and laughter 20 years ago
it was anything but it's hard saying
that your 16 year old son sees something
that nobody should ever see we remember
that day like yesterday or I do anyways
it was just a day after the Columbine
massacre when 48 hours correspondent
Bill like a tuna caught up with Josh and
his dad what did you think was happening
I was so scared I just ran underneath my
desk Josh
hadn't seen that interview since the day
and a when they first walked in they
said any jocks stand up he's white
actually had never seen it just breaks
my heart
he makes the tears rolled again I know
you're afraid but what's going through
your mind I was waiting for a sharp pain
just to hit me you know I would close my
eyes cross my fingers and you know talk
to God some of it I remember some of it
I don't the shirt pain in the side
why that out of everything that happened
seems to stick out so much because
that's what I really expected ten
students were murdered just feet away
from him in columbines library that day
not an experience that exactly fades you
really didn't want to talk about it at
first right no not at all
my parents kind of kind of forced me I
told them we had to take him to every
counselor in the state until they found
what he liked he was gone whether he
wanted to or not can you tell when he's
gone to sort of a dark place yeah I try
to check in with him a lot I try to be
like proactive in in giving him a safe
space to talk about it all that talking
has helped ease the past but what about
the future I wasn't being a dad changed
how you think about all this scares me
just the thought of your kids going to
school in my heart it scares me my brain
it tells me it's slim tune you know the
chances of a happening or super slim and
I understand that but my heart says
shouldn't they yeah I don't know if I
can handle it I'd I own ously don't
gives you a sense though I guess of what
your dad went through that day mm-hmm
dictator badgered you were wrong then
and it's still wrong your kid did your
son why that why is still unanswered
it's never answered really in the wake
of any mass shooting but for all those
survivors Josh has a message if I can be
a voice that um it'll get better it'll
never go away it'll get easier I'm
willing to be that voice in some way no
time doesn't heal much but it does offer
perspective for CBS this morning we
count Denver
20 years later you still feel the pain
and was one of the survivors you point
out yeah he's one of the survivors still